- PortoVino Wine Purses
are blowing up on Facebook
and Instagram.
And so I ordered one.
- [Justine] So let's
take it out of the box
and see what we've got here.
Here we have it.
So here's the little bladder
that we're supposed to put wine in.
I don't like wine.
I brought some beer with me
and we're going to put it in this bladder.
And see if it works.
But wait there's more.
In order to use it right?
This thing goes in here
and then this little spout
is where the wine comes out.
So you need a cup to use it.
I don't carry a glass around
with me and neither do you.
I'm gonna see if I can Macgyver
this hose straw unto it.
So that I can carry this
bag around for the day
and drink beer while I'm walking around.
I mean it doesn't look pretty
'cause I used white gaff tape.
But as you can see
I've got the beer bladder here,
inside this little compartment
and it looks like the
lining of this compartment
has insulation so at least it's
gonna keep your drinks cold,
if that's what you want.
Let's see if this works.
It works.
It's a little foamy.
Beer isn't meant to move around this much
which is why this works for wine.
But I have to say this
isn't that bad of an option.
Let's see what my coworkers think.
- [Justine] Does it work?
- Yeah.
(Justine laughs)
Oh my gosh I need one of these.
I'll be putting some wine in here though.
Or like a little mixed drink.
- I think we're going to
take it to the streets
to see if it works out in Hollywood.
- [Justine] Hey guys.
- Hey.
- [Justine] What do you
think of my wine purse?
- Wine, beer, Gatorade, water.
Put whatever you want in it.
Keep yourself hydrated,
don't drink and drive.